όπως δήποτε υπάρχει αυτός που έχει την ευθύνη που είναι ο κάπετάνιος αυτό που κάναμε
ελλάθο στην αστυνομία τήσα χρόνια ήταν ότι τέγαμε πάντα τους καπετάνιος ι φταγαμε πάντα τους
τσσερες πέντε αστυνομικούς τις βάσεις με επιθα αρχηκίές άνημα οι πινικές ανημα δηποθέσεις για διάφορα
για εγονότα και κίνους ούλους που ήταν στο μεσοδιάστημα εν τους ιδιούσαμε να ρμοδιότητες θύνες
κύριοώνου κάπνε ται αστυνομικό πορτάου παραπολλά χρόνια ια αν βγούμε είαι εξωτώρα εδώς στην εδώ
εξω από την πόρτα και ρωτήσουμε οιος είναι ο βοήθεος αρχηγός της αστυνομίας παρόλομ που
δεν έχουμε αλλά και να είχαμε δε θα εγνωρίζζαν το όνομα αυτό δε γίνεται πρέπει
να ακού προς τα όλη να αλάβουν ευθύνες και ποηθ αρχιή κυρίαστυνομικήδευθντές πρέπει ο καθένας
να έχεια αρμοδιότες καιυνες για να μπορούμε σε ένα γιαγονός το οποίον ήταν αρνητικό να
μη φτέμε πάντα των καπετανιώ υπάντα τους τεαρις πντε αστνομικούς της βασηςεπίορκαι αστυνομική έβλεπαν και
σήμερα το πρωί μια επιστολή του ενα αρχηκού για να ότι υποψίες για ασθυνομικούς που
διέρεαν στο ργανωμένο έγκλημα αριθμούς οχημάτων υποκάληψε οχημάτω που έκαναν παρακολουθήσεις διάροες που δεν ξέρω
όσο μπορεί να πρόβλη πόσο πρόβλημα μπορεί να είναι διάροι ένως θέματο σε δημοσιογράφος γιαδή
βάλαμε όλα σε ένα επίπεδο και το οργανωμένο έγκλημα κέταμο μου με αυτή την επιστολη
είναι άλλο άλησυζήησι αυτή αλλά επεία ορκια στυνομική υπάρχουν σήμερα είναι το πρόβλημα το βαθύ
πρόβλημα της αστυνομίας κατοαρχάνα πω ότι αυτό που έστειλε ήταν να προειδοποίηση η οποία ήταν
κόπιπστ οτο αντίγραφο τις αστυνομικής διααξε ήναν κατι παραπάνω και να πω εδώ ότι των
αδιαρέτις πληροφορίες με την ένεια όχι δημοσίους συμφέροντους όπως τολέτεσείς γιατί κάποιες πληροφορές που σας
δεν είοπρόσωπος τίποτα ίου είναι για το δημόσιως συμφέρον έτσι λοιπόν να το ξεκαθαρίζουμ από
για πέρα